donc là vous vous dites en temps normal
un blog sur la chaîne de fabien qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire je vais
vous expliquer donc ça lui ça fait
quelques temps que je voulais reprendre
un peu le vlog un peu à l'époque de 2016
je faisais une vidéo par jour là il
s'agit pas d'en faire une vidéo par jour
mais de reprendre un petit peu la caméra
un peu tout le temps de partager avec
vous les choses que je fais mais aussi
des propos que je pourrais pas avoir
dans des vidéos trop long qui sont
thématiques sur un sujet ça me permet
aussi d'aller un petit peu dans tous les
sens devront reprendre aussi un peu
l'essence même qui fait que j'aime bien
faire des vidéos sur des choses moins
produit j'ai de la chance depuis
quelques années d'avoir une équipe avec
moi avec tous d'avoir loïc qui fait des
montages et tout mais c'est presque
devenu tellement pros que je sais plus
faire des trucs un petit peu à larache
comme peut l'être un blog alors pas
complètement à larache parce que l'idée
de faire ce blog c'est de le faire
monter aussi pour être sûr de pouvoir
publier régulièrement et c'est là
qu'intervient cette chaire pauline
bonjour pauline qui regarde la vidéo et
qui attend vous êtes honnête avec vous
ces roches depuis peut-être deux mois je
pense qu'on parle de faire ça mais le
truc c'est que j'ai eu du mal à
reprendre la caméra en mode réflexe je
l'avais pas avec moi où j'étais un peu
trop de la tête dans le guidon pour oser
de l'emmener avec moi donc ça se
rechargent sais je m'en suis fait la
promesse que c'était le début de ce blog
mais il faut savoir que pauline tu as
reçu également d'autres roches de début
de blog depuis ces derniers temps je te
laisse leur faire voir les autres roches
de vous d'autres roches ou d'autres
choses que vous auriez dû voir en temps
normal voilà c'est maintenant
[Musique]
salut c'est une nouvelle caméra et c'est
un salut ceci est un blog je vais me
regarder dans les yeux ça fait j'ai pas
le log et ambrées depuis 2016 je crois
un dock comme ça alors on va déjà la
règle et il est trop penché vous allez
avoir mal au cou aux cheveux bleus tout
ça marche en corrélation avec la
rencontre avec une menteuse qui
s'appelle pauline et c'est pauline qui
va recevoir tous les roches
donc voilà bienvenue dans le vlog les
hollies carnet forcément je peux vous
mettre l'eau boli car quelque part faut
pas qu'un mot commence par gare ou
finissent par eau parce que je suis
obligé sinon de faire le jeu de mots
j'ai pas le choix sinon je n'entends pas
vous allez aussi avoir un peu les
coulisses de tout ce que je fais ah oui
vous allez avoir pas mal de police et un
dans ce blog vous allez voir un petit
peu tout moment des tours donc on est le
29 janvier je vais je pense créer une
nouvelle chaîne youtube qui sera en lien
dans la description sur laquelle je
mettrai ces bleus là bas n'ont peut-être
pas une nouvelle chaîne jackman sur la
chaîne secondaire est surtout permis un
robot masters je vous mets le lien de
cette chaîne à la description et c'est
là bas qu'ils auront les blogs je vais
pas alimenter la chaîne principale de
blogs qui n'intéresseront pas tout le
monde en fait peut-être si vous ça vous
intéresse vous avez le lien et vous
allez vous abonner la bague qui vous
fait râler les vidéos sortir donc je
vous fais un petit état des lieux un
petit topo pour que vous puissiez vous
raccorder à ma vie à partir de
maintenant là je suis dans les anciens
locaux que j'ai re transformer c'est là
que je filme tout nietzsche et que je
télétravail et tout ça en parallèle le
terme d'écrire mon prochain livre qui
sera sur la manipulation ah oui alors
clairement sur le blog vous saurez tout
l avance de tout le monde
autant je communie pas en avance sur les
réseaux dans le blog aussi servir à vous
raconter tout ça donc là je vais avoir
deux jours d'écriture assez intense
alors je vous en parlerai fort mesure
quand vous voyez des choses mais je vous
fais au moins le room tour de cet
endroit où je viens travailler était
vais travailler
[Musique]
c'est là où je télétravail comme vous
pouvez voir on est sur un gros gros
télétravail en termes de simpson
avant quand arrivé il y avait mon bureau
qui étaient là bas
ici il y avait le bureau de loïc et ici
il y avait le bureau de famille à
deuxième bureau libre donc là maintenant
quand on rentre ici c'est le poste
twitch c'est vrai que je fais mais live
sur twitter et je sais pas si vous avez
vraiment vu le derrière et tout ça mais
je vous emmène quand même ici vous avez
un truc incroyable des toilettes est ici
la réserve
voilà vous connaissez maintenant cet
espace en est confiné je viens
travailler depuis ici
[Musique]
bon réunion de crise avec vous je vous
dis un petit peu ce qui ce qu'il est
sorti de de ce cerveau chelou j'ai pris
des notes que tu as fait ça bien quand
même ça c'est mon père des notes c'est
un peu comme une kindle mais inversés en
gros voilà ce qui se passe dans les
choses visibles que vous allez voir
arriver d'être ce sera pas encore passé
à la sortie ce blog j'en ai aucune idée
mais en gros comme je peux pas jouer je
vais faire confie le mentalisme 2 et je
vais l'appeler au confinement taxi si
j'avais fait ça le 7 mai il y avait plus
de cent mille personnes qui avaient
regardé c'était en live sur twente
chemin tube facebook aussi mais c'était
un spectacle 100% interactif je vais
lancer 1 2 le 22 novembre ce sera john
mon anniversaire je vais pas communiqué
dessus mais en vrai c'est le cadeau que
tu manques et je vais faire ça depuis la
pole au théâtre on avait tourné des
vidéos mois de juin la vidéo vous avez
vu paraître au mois de juillet sur la
chaîne avait des gens qui étaient là
dedans des écrans je vais me remettre
dans ce système la vente là si on veut
commencer là comme le sceptre ça veut
dire qu'on a trois jours pour tout
mettre en place pour renvoyer la com
pour que quinze jours après en ce sens
le spectacle
j'ai aussi décidé d'écrire un nouveau
lit parce qu'on peut être pas se laisser
abattre et je pars aller durant des
années que que ce livre là soient mort
nées à cause de la période
je vais écrire un nouveau livre moins
d'être perso et plus sûr du savoir que
j'ai et ça va être sur la manipulation à
usage des gentils jean ses terres en
restant dans le camp des gentils tu
assez chaud je vais essayer d'écrire
c'est un petit peu aujourd'hui avant
d'aller chez pierre et j'en ai déjà
parlé à mon éditeur il est chaud pour
monsieur comme ça me sortirait au mois
de mai il remplacerait un petit peu le
dernier livre un jeu c'est dans
l'historique ce serait mon cinquième
bouquin donc voir aussi si je peux
écrire ce genre de libre aussi vite et
sur un stade sur tik tok plus je
reprends les fun fact quotidienne
collant à l'actif du jour en plus j'ai
un coup de main au moins ya jérémy qui
est le nouvel arrivé dans la boîte il
m'a déçu
regarder un petit peu ce qu'il ya comme
actu lui avoir les fun fact qui peut y
avoir et que je complète en fait avec
les miettes ça c'est dans le godet
visible et dans le côté non visible en
avance aussi sur la boutique vous savez
on avait sorti cérébral il ya quelques
temps
250 pages avec ed et nîmes eh bien il va
y avoir des surprises à côté un peu le
plan de confinement est un peu le plan
de sauvegarde aussi tout ça parce qu'il
faut bien faire des trucs mais sans
rogner sur la passion c'est à dire qu'un
nouveau livre ça me chauffe grave
ce spectacle interactif ça me change
grave faire plus de vidéos ça me choque
grave donc ses joueurs et je pense que
ça peut vous plaire du coup on arrive à
la maison grise est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un à la maison grise et j'ai dû
moi-même
est ce que quelqu'un à la maison claire
est ce que je peux te mettre comme
vignette de cette vidéo avec plaisir
mais tu vas fort bout de piques mais
c'est le direct ça va super fait un peu
con toi tout tu fais des bus en ligne
est tu bloques toi qu'est ce que tu fais
un peu ouais j'ai bien aimé cette caméra
je les achetais j'aime aussi il faut
vraiment des gens très sérieux quelque
chose j'ai 7x japonais salon allemand
allait tout cesar 6 existe mais là
j'aime bien l'aspect scénique valait
vraiment fait pour bloquer les craintes
belle mais le stabilisateur et les
chants des faucons pas le blog revient à
moi c'est ça c'est pas une association
la carmi un peu ça vous dit mais moi je
vais appeler ça la mesure est une mali
car pour les matchs et des jeux de mots
j'ai vu lui clouer au lit car bon aller
2 1 avec le code promo rhino licard est
jetée que demeurer tient également aux
big three au lit car ça c'est moi c'est
un crayon russe oui c'est vrai il a fait
de temps je veux qu'il va s'appeler loïc
armé d'un attentat pas fait un truc un
quart rick aulika le mollica arrêts
c'est fou si vraiment à des besoins un
jeu de mots fred tu m'appelles [ __ ] ça
c'est beau ça c'est beau chat arrive et
ça sert à ça tu vois hélas 10 alors que
ça [ __ ] les jeux il est fait de fonds
non c'est moi qui suis julie assez ça si
on va en fait c'est bon je passe entre
deux personnes du coup le fonds se met
en fout parce que c'est toi
il veut te faire un gros coup c'est sa
déco livre une vidéo de pierre strauss
fils passe à des gens au souffle coupé
par mc lain je triche avant le jeu de
société en live pour les bonnes
questions ou catégorie des cartes uno
pour jouer
tac ensuite orange peut tricher
après on peut pas trop triché 1 dans ce
jeu non mais on peut choisir mes
questions comme d'hab appel - si tu veux
arnaquer les gens c'est mon métier comme
les jeux récents ce que je suis
mentaliste radiothon spectacle tu as
fait le test d une défiance sa d'agents
secrets
franchement c'est la vidéo que j'ai le
plus qui fait affaires 2008 en 2000
c'est vrai déjà il a toujours un contrat
dans les mains quand je regarde des
contre-feux blanche s'avérer essentielle
des trucs ya zéro chaque fois on a ici
d'y signer là bas j'ai jamais le morceau
sur total 0 gage membres et bien sûr
jean of les petites photos miniatures
comme ça c'est vrai à blanzat x tu vois
on fait les miniatures de vie nature
toujours avoir le contexte donc là c'est
un jeu de réflexion un peu un peu de
culture générale c'est ça qui est plus
intelligent sur nous plus fort que
google c'est avec le petit mouvement
capillaire c'est ce cas c'était
incroyable moi je crois que la coupe
mulet rajoute de l'intérêt à bientôt
alors est-ce que je vais plus
intelligent que le moteur de recherche
le plus sûr du monde non plusieurs
organes elles sont belles elles sont
bien et c'est là où ses célèbres les
gens se rendent compte qu'ils ont fait
toujours des sons avec nous au en fait
on a toujours les cinq mêmes têtes 1re
finale
je m'installe temps infini à huy ont
réfléchi du coup comment elle est
guillaume battant mais pour moi
réfléchir savoir une tête n'ont même pas
l'appareil regardent comme si tu veux
aller au bout j'avais dans les pouces
mais c'est ça oui chacun fait des photos
pour s'assurer moi je tiens à coeur joie
[Musique]
jean de réfection s ok croquis de demain
plus ski j'ai trouvé la réponse
si j'étais du genre c'est sa solution
des propres capacités dans lequel et ben
voila ca bienvenue ange bleu sa part sur
un sur un live tu résumes anti alive
d'un petit quart d'heure modifia nous
sommes 5 novembre cette oreille zone et
de l'ouche et honda en télétravail mais
là je vais chez loïc pendant tallinn et
une vidéo ce qu'on a de la chance avec
l'oeil qu'on est indemne et m'a plu et
après on donne on doit tourner donc je
vous emmène d'abord voir donc wavi le
heat lagarde
et c'est parce que vraiment d'une droite
il met cinq sets comme la part des
titres cette semaine le tueur fut
scellée voire de vlog et de contenus sur
internet
non c'est là dedans que se fabriquent
les génériques c'est exactement c'est
ici vous voyez toujours mon appareil qui
est prévue avec m'avait si jamais
d'autres auxquelles je ss générique
gérer le coin un créatif le coin cave le
coin coin mercerie dos je monterai pas
ce qu'il y'a pas ce que c'est c'est la
voiture c'est le retirer et là vous avez
bas je suppose que vous venez voir le
montage on aime bel timeline de type
espaces d'internet on a des cats
on a deux trois quêtes deux trois
pilotes se passe pas grand chose sur la
table
outre sa passe et sept-îles d'os suis là
je pense qu'il servait pas lu je suis là
il sert à rien dans un mail à ses yeux
que le viroquois si tu veux j'avais un
bon on a ça allait du coup tu penses que
ça va être qu'est qui passe comment il
va réagir le train de naldo balle il a
déjà dit il ya eu fraude on lui a dit
laquelle il fait bon bah on va avoir
laquelle on va bien trouver la fraude
parce que j'ai trouvé je vais saisir le
conseil suprême - c'est le coup de ouais
alors non en fait là c'est fini on
arrête de compter parce qu'on n'a pas
fini de compter chez je m'en fous là je
suis président et ensuite devant c'est
quand même quand tu fais un jeu de
société et on n'a pas dit à quel point
on s'arrêter finalement ordonné que
repasse devant dans le jeu tu as tu es
bon on arrête arrête là chouinard est là
je gagne et qu'on arrête là j'ai un peu
moi j'en ai marre perso de jouer j j
avais vraiment besoin de ça te fait
bizarre hallyday dans les anciens
bureaux
c'est très étrange ça paraît toupiti
maintenant c'est quoi ta tête avec 86
voulons les petits freestyle nouveau
blouson ce test il connaît
des secours
en fait c'est l'influencé que j'affiche
tu vois un objectif la chute de kadhafi
et il ya doute ça me ferait cannes on y
va ou quoi allez on va tourner au
contour en élaborant apparemment pierre
il m'avait fait un plan hier ce qu'il a
vu traîner la caméra faut juste et moi
j'ai la caméra de fabien olicard lorsque
je veux sur son blog
venez vous abonner à la chaîne de la
maison meilleure chaîne de blogging to
you tube
la maison le lien est dans la
description et il est venu ici en sous
titre c'est incroyable nouvelle caméra
les biens justement tu as pas plus le
seul moment intéressant là on appelle ça
un ordinateur et lampes et monde environ
que fait-on attestation huit questions
pour me rendre au travail carte vidéo km
à mios qui tue et on tourne expérience 3
est-ce que ça
[Musique]
un problème aux couples qui joue vouloir
cool à fréthun la dame
on ne peut pas filmer ses bons et onana
veut pas voir le code bien mais pas du
tout des codes et tu sais c'est pas
l'école tourne axe on va tourner les
vidéos enfin parce qu'il doit être déjà
16 heures et qu'on a fait plein d'autres
choses
on a mis en ligne la vidéo qui sort ce
soir déjà c'est pas mal il a un bon
début est ce que le set up est prêt ça
ressemble quoi de ces tables de fabien
olicard s'il vous plaît monsieur de dire
quelque chose comme ça hein c'est comme
battre on regarde ça de plus près là
c'est une caméra qui permet de filmer
montée devant l'objectif
un prompteur permet de d'efficacité les
griquas cité dans la lumière le côté de
titres au sabre laser leur micro qu'il
perde de boules leçon sur votre droite
une lumière permet d'éclairer la face
notre mentaliste préférés ici
c'est celui qui lui souffle les blagues
et les maires ça qu'elles sont bien les
prêtres et sa tête le décor voilà
[Musique]
et moi j'ai pas de café par c'est ça le
bail n'est pas de café pour un jeu
vraiment ces mecs
bad café waters capter watts
question pour un café quand a été
inventé le café existe et c'est une
bonne chose
combien de capter l but aujourd'hui un
deux trois cafés c'était 3 4 et donc
c'est une nouvelle agence bien venu
d'ailleurs je ne la commenterai pas je
suis ici et en appui au moins deux chez
weight hockey troisième question c'est
la question qui définit toutes les
questions hockey qu'est ce qu'une
question quelque chose qui applique une
réponse au hockey avec une interrogation
normalement non parce que je peux
vraiment une question d'un interrogatif
doit pas y avoir une question d'un
interrogative et à quelle heure demain
c'est pas interrogatif ouais mais une
interrogation dedans on avait le ton
n'est pas interrogatif d'avoir plus
longues années je me tiens droit moi
aussi me dire laura c'est une illusion
d'optique c'est comme un dieu ah bin là
tu fais très bien l'objet d'un verset
pas que je suis c'est que je suis trop
loin
c'est pas mal allez c'est parti monsieur
au lit car vous allez dans votre
tournage
[Musique]
lolo soir on a finir on a fini la
réalité dans 55 du matin
c'est faux il est 19 heures le quitte
oui bah c'est sensiblement la même chose
là c'est pas pour payer sa dégaine
caméra il prend un accent que on n'a pas
tant défini que ça va c coupé comme l'à
propos et en vrai il est en recherche de
l'accent québécois depuis le départ
prenez-ça locaux ignorant que ce curieux
rigoler ou belge non je suis tout sur la
russie la bienvenue j'ai voulu faire la
[ __ ] d'effets de l'autre oeil quand
même type mais je crois qu'on a un peu
fatigué mon auto allez on se tient à 16
ans nîmes à la belle je suis pas triste
en ce moment attention jérémy sa film je
filme ce que tu fais on était fous j'ai
travaillé avec moi depuis septembre 2020
et jérémy et assistant de production et
coauteur de certaines vidéos exactement
ce qu'on prépare là aujourd'hui on
prépare une vidéo pour tous une miror
tâche vous faire voir un petit c'est un
peu comme ma vidéo du million c'est une
vidéo en brique et voilà ça c'est le
plan de la vidéo temps je leur ai tout
fait voir steven chu tout ce qui est qui
ont vu faut qu'on les interdits et il le
voit après la diffusion
ouais après donc bref le programme du
jour c'est qu'on va travailler là-dessus
ce matin et cet après-midi en
travaillant projet qui s'appelle le cube
de diamants qu'une fiction qu'on va
essayer de sortir sur la chaîne youtube
la première fiction de la chaîne en
quatre ans
bref vous allez suivre ça de l'intérieur
j'espère que ça va vous allez abonnez
vous à cette chaîne si j'ai mis ça sur
la nouvelle chaîne
et puis sinon abonnez vous quand même
parce que cela peut aller ma bosse et
moi
donc ce méchant qui comprendra plus
d'informations et pour alexandre
[Musique]
à
geo
dans le pack
[Musique]
juste le plan de paix ça fonctionne on a
une vidéo interactive en mode enquêtes
en cours
il faut dire que la fin de la vidéo j'ai
enfin cette histoire de trois heures
[Musique]